hi my name is Adnan Habib I'm currently
the head of Department in the education
division I joined the Road Commission in
2010 as a faculty member I hold a PhD in
electrical engineering and I've been
working as an educator for nearly 13
years now I felt at that time that I
needed some professional development
activities and training to enhance my
capabilities when I started marketing
for the certifications I felt that PMP
was the most appropriate for me to
enhance my skills it really helped me
this blend between online live sessions
and self-learning videos as well as case
studies and test papers get me enough
confidence this allowed me first
appointed as the head of department for
quality
it was a newly established Department my
work under that Mega project has put
enough confidence by positive
experience with simply learn actually
pushed me to I've been exposed
to more advanced concepts in quality and
planning these skills I have acquired
allowed me for a second consecutive
promotion with this positively fire
impact of my professional development
through sampling earned Services I have
decided to
enroll in other programs the pull to
program in data science it was an
interesting a very Rich Blend between
simple learning expertise into training
and online delivery deep
content by recognized institutions like
University of wood after completing
this program I'm now better equipped to
help my students into being ready for
the job market thumbs up for for simply
run and they really helped me into being
a better professional both I have
built-in expertise in the various Fields
but also in depth because the techniques
at the knowledge they prepare and
deliver
with renowned Partners is helping me to
improve myself and develop myself and
be better equipped to serve my community
to serve my profession and to explore
and add up to Opportunities and changes
I might encounter in the future so thank
you simply learn